the pharmaceutical industry is debating
whether to issue one of the biggest
recalls in modern history the recall
would affect a wide array of
over-the-counter cold medicines
including some products bearing the
brand names of Mucinex Tylenol Sudafed
NyQuil Benadryl the reason well
according to the government these
products don't work at all now to be
clear as we'll explain in a second some
Benadryl and Sudafed products do work
according to the government we're
talking about a certain but very popular
subset of these over-the-counter
products that use a specific ingredient
nearly a decade ago in 2015 researchers
at the University of Florida said that
they found conclusive evidence that many
non-prescription decongestants didn't
work quote scientific evidence continues
to show that the most popular products
on the market containing phenylephrine
are ineffective phenylephrine to be
clear is used in certain drugs like
over-the-counter Sudafed it's not used
in the brand of Sudafed that you have to
get from the pharmacist